salut saviez vous que vous étiez capable
d'écrire un livre en 30 jours non ben
moi non pourtant c'est le principe du
nano louis mo alors derrière ce nom bien
celle où se trouve un concept sympa le
national novel writing monde est une
idée géniale que j'ai découverte l'année
dernière le but du jeu c'est d'écrire
cinquante mille mots en seulement 30
jours soit environ 175 pages c'est à
dire un petit roman comme la guerre des
mondes par exemple excusez du peu le
concept phare du créateur du nano seynod
pelote nos problèmes c'est à dire il n'y
a pas d'idée il n'y a pas de problème on
n'a pas besoin d'avoir une idée pour
écrire quelque chose aux nano à la
limite c'est même mieux vous allez
devoir séquestré votre éditeur intérieur
vous savez pas qui c'est c'est la petite
voix qui dans votre tête fait non mais
ça c'est pas terrible non ça va y refait
le savent asie reprend le vous devez pu
l'écouter pendant un mois c'est pas le
délire une fois n'est pas coutume vous
allez oublier la qualité au bénéfice de
la quantité le but c'est de faire de la
matière et décrire ces fichus 1666 maux
quotidiens 1,2 3 j'aime beaucoup cette
idée parce que c'est une approche
complètement kamikaze la création et
c'est à dire que si vous vous y mettez
vous allez voir que vous allez écrire
beaucoup de choses inutiles voire des
choses idiotes et c'est très bien comme
ça le but étant de faire une première
création un premier jet parce qu'au
final on s'autorise pas assez à creissan
de jugement de valeur sans porter
soi-même un propre jugement sur ce qu'on
est en train de faire en temps réel
c'est d'abord de faire sortir quelque
chose de soi c'est l'idée du nano on
pose des mots des mots des mots des mots
des mots qu'on cherche pas à se relire
ou à se corriger on se juge pas on se
relit pas et au bout de 30 jours on a
cinquante mille mots on à 175 pages on a
un premier jet et là vous avez tout le
temps après de le retoucher de le
reprendre d'euros modifier des choses
d'en supprimer d'en changer
peu importe puisque vous avez déjà une
matière complète ce sera beaucoup plus
simple et beaucoup plus motivant alors
on peut le faire à n'importe quel moment
de l'année peu importe d'ailleurs il
n'ya pas une date précise à respecter
mais il ya un mois qui est commun qui
est globale à tout le monde dans le
monde entier depuis la création du nano
il ya plus de dix ans c'est le mois de
novembre
le monde entier se met à écrire
l'intérêt de le faire au mois de
novembre c'est qu'on peut rejoindre une
communauté qui est dans le même délire
que nous il ya des rencontres il ya un
kick off qui se fait la veille du
lancement on se retrouve tous
il ya des rencontres dans des bars est
complètement sauvage s'est organisée
sans être organisé vous même vous pouvez
créer un endroit où l'ena d'auteur elena
douteuses vont pouvoir se rejoindre et
écrire avec vous sont des espèces de
réunion pour s'encourager pour se
stimuler pour pas être tout seul à
écrire chez soi d'ailleurs cette année
les nains hauteur de france ont déclaré
la guerre aux nanos teur de norvège et
de corée du sud c'est à dire que sur les
sites internet on met le nombre de mots
qu'on a écrit quotidiennement tous les
nains auteurs français se cumulent on
accumule les scores et on compare avec
ceux de la norvège et de la corée du sud
parce que la règle du jeu c'est quand
même l'honnêteté personne ne viendra
vérifier si vous avez bien écrit vos
maux quotidiens personne ne viendra voir
le contenu il n'y a rien d'autre à
gagner que la satisfaction personnelle
d'avoir fait son premier jet de son
premier roman ou d'autre chose
d'ailleurs et vous l'avez peut-être
compris je suis en plein dedans moi
aussi cette année j'ai découvert le nano
l'année dernière via le super livre
qu'elle est sorti son créateur crise
bâti dans le milieu on l'appelle dieu je
vous mets un lien dans la description
vers ce livre c'est comment écrire un
roman en 30 jours s'expliquent tout les
fondamentaux du nano semaine par semaine
c'est stimulant c'est captivant et c'est
très très drôle
en france d'ailleurs nous avons une
mascotte également nous avons une
mascotte c'est une espèce de deux
minutes heure sous forme de poules et de
cocotte-minute en fait il ya un site
français qui regroupe toutes ces
initiatives et qui vous permet aussi
d'être épaulé c'est la première fois que
vous le faites je vous met également le
lien dans la description dans la
description jouer tous les liens dont
vous pourriez avoir besoin je vous avais
partager le pouvoir ultime de la
baseline quand on avait parlé de la
créativité qu'on avait parlé aussi de la
procrastination est bien le nano est 100
% basée sur le pouvoir de la deadline et
sa puissance créatrice
n'hésitez pas à tenter l'aventuré même
si là on est déjà le 14 novembre peu
importe vous pourrez faire du 14
novembre au 14 décembre c'est vous qui
choisissez
même si au moment où vous allez prendre
votre crayon où vous allez vous poser
devant votre ordi vous n'avez aucune
idée de ce dont vous allez parler c'est
pas grave c'est mieux même je les dis
vous écrivez sans juger de la qualité
mais pour mettre en marche un processus
intérieur
s'il ya des nano touch ou des nano touch
qui regarde cette vidéo je vous souhaite
bon courage pour les 26
mille mots qui vous reste environ d'ici
la fin du mois n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs
à vous faire connaître dans les
commentaires ou s'il y en a qui désirent
se lancer vous pouvez me dire aussi ça
me fera rire de voir un peu qu'ils
participent aux délires moi de mon côté
j'ai un petit peu de retard mais c'est
que j'ai prévu un peu plus que cinquante
mille mots mais voilà c'est pas très
grave je vais me rattraper
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère que ça vous aura plus que
ça vous aura ouvert l'esprit un autre
mode de création qui est plus bourrin
mais qui permet de faire sortir des
chausse de soi même avant de les juger
n'oubliez pas c'est très important de
mettre un pouce en l'air parce que des
fois vous aimez bien mais vous oubliez
dommage quand même vous pouvez également
vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
et rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao